Spiders are amazing.
We’ve learned this mainly from observation.
From comparing webs, body shapes,
and seeing the outrageous adaptations
of spiders in action.
Now, close reads of spider genomes
are showing that we don’t know the half it.
Looking back through time,
to see how spiders have evolved
has been especially difficult.
Fossil evidence has shown us early ancestors.
But the speed of their evolution
has confounded scientists.
Starting in 2014, two different teams
used genomics to compare 100’s of genes
from 40 spiders.
They found that some orb weavers--
web making spiders--are more genetically similar
to webless spiders than the rest
of the orb-weaving group.
This suggests that web-weaving must have
evolved twice, or much earlier in a common ancestor.
A later study comparing 3400 active genes in
70 species indicated that webless,
ground-dwelling spiders, such as jumping spiders
diversified much faster than the web weavers.
The silk genes are where the true complexity of spider genomes
comes into focus.
All spiders can make silk.
And they use it for many things:
Webs
Trapping prey
Egg casings
Transport and more
Silk genes have been difficult to characterize
because they code for very large proteins
with highly repetitive regions.
But genome reads of silk glands are showing
there are a lot more silk genes than previously thought.
Take the golden orb weaver genome-
it codes for 28 silk genes and 8 of them
were unknown before.
The genome of cobwebweaving spiders revealed
a whopping 209 potential silk and glue components.
These findings may help bioengineers harness
silk’s remarkable strength and flexibility
to make artificial silk.
Understanding spider venom has been daunting
because it can involve a cocktail
of up to 1000 different chemicals and the mixture
varies from one spider to the next.
Scientists have made progress in characterizing
black widow spider venom but getting a
genome sequence has proven difficult.
Instead they turned to the genome of its relative,
the common house spider.
47 toxins known as latrotoxins were found
in common house spider venom,
even though these spiders aren’t known
to have painful bites.
This venom cocktail is different than the black widow’s,
which includes a toxin called  alpha-latrotoxin,
that does attack vertebrate cells.
This may have arisen so that black widows
could ensnare prey with back bones like lizards.
Curiously, the house spider’s latrotoxin genes
match up best with a bacterial gene.
So, researcher’s think a microbe’s gene somehow
got transferred into the ancestor
of both the house and black widow spider.
These new spider venom findings will help scientists
refine the search for new drugs and therapies.
The complexity of the few spider genomes that have
been sequenced indicate many challenges ahead.
But as this data becomes available to scientists
--the web of spider discoveries will continue to grow.